-Please welcome back to the show
the one, the only, Jack Black,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Thank you. Whoo!
Thank you.
-Nobody --
Nobody makes an entrance
like Jack Black.
You okay, bro?
-I had an idea.
I was gonna rock with the band
to kill some time
'cause I don't have
anything to say.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I was like, "Don't worry.
Let's just rock with the band,
sing about Seth Meyers,"
and I didn't have a mike though.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I got over there
and I just started singing
Could you hear
any of the lyrics?
-No, we didn't hear anything
[ Laughter ]
Were they some pretty --
Were they pretty --
♪♪ -Seth Meyer, he's not a liar
-See, these are
really good lyrics.
♪♪ -Something else,
man is on fire ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-You just didn't
think it through.
You left out some of the details
before you got into it.
-I miss you, man.
How have you been?
-I've been really good.
[ Laughter ]
I miss you.
It's always great to see you
-You're crushing it out here
I love your work.
[ Laughter ]
-Let me give you --
Let me let you take a little bit
of a breather just to show tha
this is not something --
This is not just
a one-time thing.
This is the premiere of
"Jumanji,"
and you brought it
for that red carpet as well.
-I do.
-This is a man who is gettin
a lot of height,
in front of The Rock no less
Look at that.
-It's true.
-You had some rest time.
You found some time
for yourself.
-I did.
[ Laughter ]
I took a little breather.
When you go that hard,
you have to take a breather.
-You have to take a breather
Your children --
We were talking backstage.
You got a decade on me
with your kids.
They're 13 and 11.
And were they psyched?
Did you bring them?
Did they like the premiere
-Will I be out of breath
all the way
through this segment
is the question.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Will I catch my breath
before we cut to commercial?
And the answer,
I'm afraid, is no.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪ Seth Meyer, he's not a liar
♪♪ Ooh, mama, mama,
back on fire ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I didn't work out --
Thank you.
I didn't work out the second
half of that stanza.
-Yeah.
-Something, something.
-You put four -- you need --
you need, like a fourth rhyme.
-What were we talking about,
my boys?
-Yeah, your boys.
Were they a fan?
Are they proud to see their da
on the big screen?
-They are fans,
but they are reluctant fans.
-Okay.
-They're at that age, 11 and 13,
where they're, like,
everything I say and do
is inherently uncool.
But I think that's natural
-Yeah, but it must be hard
because I think a lot of dads,
like, never were cool.
-Yeah.
-You were cool.
Like, it must be hard for them
Do you feel, like, they don'
quite fully understand?
-I know that they love me
underneath their teenage angst
-Right.
-And they did have
a blast at the premiere.
-Uh-huh. Good.
[ Laughter ]
-And my boy -- my oldest boy
Sammy, said,
"I'm gonna review this movie."
He reviews a lot of movies and
he puts them on his Instagram.
And I said, "Sammy, you do not
have to review -- I'm in it.
It's gonna be weird if you
review a movie your dad's in."
He's like,
"No, no, I really liked it
I'm going to give it an 8.5.
-Wow.
-And I was like,
"That's certified fresh."
-That's not bad, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But I was like, "If you'r
gonna review my movie,
can't we get it up to a 9? 9.2?"
-Does he get nines?
Are there a lot of nines?
-Oh, yeah, "Joker" got a 10.
-Oh, so that's rough.
-And I know what
you're thinking.
"How could you let your
13-year-old see 'Joker'?
That's bad parenting,"
and I say, it was genius.
It was -- I enjoyed it,
and my boy loved it.
Sometimes I do the wrong thing
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And you don't
beat yourself up for it.
-I do beat myself up for it.
-Yeah.
-Parenting is hard.
You're always wondering
if you're blowing it.
-When you walked out of "Joker
after it was over,
did you have a moment of, like
maybe let's not let Mom
know about "Joker"?
-There was a moment
during the movie,
and those of you who saw i
probably know which part
I'm thinking about
where I was like,
"I hope that Tanya
never sees this movie
and sees what
I've exposed my --"
Yeah, 'cause there's definitel
possible trauma
that could take place if you
take a kid to that movie.
-You got to take your kids
because of filming "Jumanji,
you got to take them to Hawaii
yeah?
-Yeah.
-Did they enjoy that?
Did they have a good time?
-Yes, the boys had a blast
Well, you know,
the new "Jumanji,"
we got a lot
of different locales.
In the first one, it was all
jungle, and it was in Hawaii
We shot in
the jungles of Hawaii.
-Yeah.
-You don't think of jungle
when you think Hawaii,
but in the center of the island,
there was a lot
of jungley places and --
[ Laughter ]
And so, they could have come t
any of the locations
'cause we went snow
this time, in Canada.
We went to the desert dune
in New Mexico,
but they wanted to come to
Hawaii, and we partied at the --
There's, like, some water slides
at this one --
Oh, who cares?
[ Laughter and applause ]
I got tired in
the middle of that story.
-You lost it.
You started thinking about how
sweet it must have been
to be on a water slide.
You don't have to talk at all.
You're just on a sweet tube,
letting gravity do the work.
-Just go crazy with the scissors
later and just edit this
into one streamlined segment
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Just where you're just, like
popping from story to story.